- What I see when I look
at the rectal tool kit
is a great example of problem solving
in the intelligence world.
Technology is designed
to fix hard problems.
My name is Dr. Vince Houghton.
I'm the historian and curator here
at the International Spy Museum.
The International Spy Museum
has the largest public display
of espionage artifacts
anywhere in the world.
From time to time, I'll
see visitors looking
at our escape and evasion case,
which is all the tools to help you get out
of a bad situation.
And you can just watch their eyes
as they go from artifact to artifact,
until they lock on to the rectal tool kit.
It's almost like you can
see their brain working,
and then the light bulb pops:
"Are you kidding me?"
What I have in my hand is a
CIA-issued rectal tool kit,
given to CIA officers during
the height of the cold war.
The materials that rectal
tool kits are made of
vary to a degree.
But you want to make sure
that you have a material
that does not have the
chance of having sharp edges
or any kind of splintering effect,
because of the sensitive
places that we're putting this.
It also has to be finely machined.
The seals have to be very tight,
not only to prevent things from seeping
into the actual tool kit itself,
but also so that you don't
have any kind of sharp edges
or ridges that could possibly injure you
when you're using this
particular artifact.
What the tool kit allows them to do
is have on hand ways to get them
out of a bad situation:
to pick a lock, to drill
your way through a door,
to kind of carve your way
to make a small tunnel.
Think of all the different ways
that you could maybe
break out of a jail cell,
like the things that people
might bake into a cake.
Well, these are all encompassed
inside this tool kit
because guards are
gonna put you in a place
and say, "Oh, the door's locked,
we don't have to really pay a lot
of attention to this guy,"
because they don't think that
you have these tools with you.
And if you do, you have a huge advantage.
These people who work
in intelligence agencies
building these gadgets
are given some impossible tasks.
And they're trying to figure out ways
to solve the impossible problem.
So this is a great
indication of that, right?
You present a problem,
say, if our guy's captured
and he's searched,
let's say he's strip-searched,
how do we provide him with the tools
to help him escape from
this terrible situation?
Well, there's your rectal tool kit.
And sometimes, this is a
matter of life and death.